hey youtubers it's Charlie so thank you
so much everyone that submitted
questions on my listen review in my
bonus video generally about ninety
percent of them had to do with a certain
barn but that is totally to be expected
just in general you guys had some really
good theories about the barn as well as
Missy Danny pink and some of the bigger
twists and series eight so keep it up
the TV is always worth talking about
I'll announce the winner of the giveaway
at the end of this video the next round
is going to start whenever I post my
episode 5 review so if you're just
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe if you want to participate in
that so big reminder careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet I'll wait just a sec okay
ready here we go question number one
matthew tam asks if Gallifrey was locked
in the pocket universe how did the
TARDIS get there so there are a couple
ways you can think about this you know
one that was not Gallifrey or you could
also think of it as possibly being
gallop rate but Moffat never really
intending to tell us one way or the
other definitively the reason I
specifically said it was Gallifrey in my
review video is because I read a spoiler
from TV Guide magazine that series 8
would include a quote-unquote stopover
on Gallifrey but not a proper doctor
visit obviously they were talking about
this episode and since TV Guide is
generally known for being pretty good
with its facts I had no reason to doubt
them some of you have pointed out that
the way they cut the scene with the John
Hurt footage causes a few logic issues
because gal Freight does not have a blue
sky so if TV Guide was wrong and it's
not Gallifrey it's probably Karn just
because I think they're turning the barn
into this visual trilogy for the doctors
past remember first off he goes to Karn
to become the war doctor to regenerate
into the John Hurt doctor I know some of
you don't want to call him the war
doctor then he goes back in the 50th to
detonate the moment and then recently we
found out that's where he grew up before
going to the Academy let's call that the
not Gallifrey explanation so the other
explanation is is that you know Moffat
has kind of a timing why me ID in his
head it isn't completely thought out in
the way that a lot of you know fan
theories are obviously he took them
there in the 50th so I think if you were
to press him at a convention and ask him
the question he would use some of the
same logic it's important to remember
that this episode listen was written
after the 50th anniversary so whenever
they were writing the war
in this scene right here Moffat did not
know that he was going to take them back
there in series eight I think a lot of
the continuity issues can just be
attributed to that fact I still think
that it's Gallifreyan Moffat just tried
to work within his own pre-established
cannon and it got a little messy but
whatever the explanation really is I
don't think it's going to help the
doctor bring Gallifrey back I think
Gallifrey won't come back anytime soon I
think that missing the finale will have
something to do with it but not bringing
you back maybe just finding it I think
the big takeaway from all this is that
if you get really confused just try to
think like Moffat you know if you were
Moffat what would be an interesting
story to tell and just try and keep it
simple on to question number two step of
Graham seven asks do you think the
doctor will ever show Clara the toy
soldier or realize that she was the one
who gave it to him so the doctor stores
all kinds of things from all three
generations inside the TARDIS so it's
totally possible that the toy soldier is
like somewhere in a bin somewhere the
doctor is known to forget things so it's
possible that he's forgotten it or he
could totally know where it is I think
the toy soldier itself is more important
as a metaphor for the finale as it
relates to Danny pink and Missy I do
really like the idea though that the
first doctor kept that with him whenever
he went to the Academy and then later
whenever you stole the TARDIS but on to
question number three DBZ Axl asks any
thoughts on the Courtney girl from coal
Hill School she's been mentioned or
appeared in most of the episodes so far
so I think there are a couple
explanations one is that they're just
trying to create this you know separate
universe inside Doctor Who at coal Hill
School and they want to populate it with
people who feel like they exist there
whenever klar on the doctor aren't
around the other explanation is that yes
she is extra special and it'll have
something to do with a future episode
the synopsis for the caretaker episode i
think it's episode 6 implies the story
for the entire episode will be localized
to coal Hill School the episode was
written by gareth edwards who also wrote
The Lodger and closing time two big
episodes where the doctor went and spent
time away from his companions so it's
totally possible the doctor could go to
coal Hill School in this one episode and
Courtney would be like the person that
spends a lot of time with him on to
question number four Davis asks is Danny
pink ever going to go on a proper
adventure with the doctor or will he
always be stuck in present
game so Samuel Anderson clarified his
status on the show a little bit he said
he's a companion to the companion so if
he does go on an adventure with the
doctor it won't be without Clara I did
read somewhere that he will actually go
onboard the TARDIS at some point I don't
know if it's in the next couple of
episodes or if it's not till much much
later there's actually a funny story
that he told about you know where he was
when he found out that he got the show
he said that his agent called him and
said you know you got the job here on
Doctor Who and he was so excited that he
was in a room full of friends and he
told them all but the agent called back
and said oh by the way don't tell anyone
you got the job he said I just told a
room full of people it just reinforces
the idea that Samuel Anderson knows his
comedy just as well as he knows his
drama so I'm really looking forward to
more Danny pink in series eight but on
to question number five programmer X
asks was there something under the bed
what was under the covers and what is
under your bed so yes there was
definitely something under the bed I do
think it was a new monster that Moffat
just never intends to show us like we're
never gonna see what's under that sheet
you can interpret it as you want but i
think you know from a storytelling
perspective it's amazing think about it
this way Moffat never has to spend any
money on special effects or makeup you
can just stick anything he wants under
that blanket Capaldi's doctor has been
backtracking a lot during series 8 so
it's totally possible that there's some
alternate explanation and it's either
Clara or some other time traveler like
another version of the doctor just
reaching out and grabbing people they
kind of implied that with the copy cup
too it's just one of those things that I
think he thought would be a really good
storytelling device but on to question
number six dark Nico studio asks why
hasn't the doctor been trying to find
Gallifrey or repair his mistakes of the
past I actually think that that's what
all the blackboard equations are about
like the quantum physics equations
Moffat said that when he wrote listen he
wanted to show what the doctor does
whenever he's all by himself with
nothing to do so this is what I think is
happening the doctors just taking his
time finding Gallifrey it's not going
anywhere and the Time Lords are safe I
mean as far as we know this story I
think is more of a pause in the action
you know fixing mistakes of the past
it's hard to tell how urgent he was
whenever he said that line I mean he
wasn't shouting it aclara like I must
fix mistakes right now so the short
answer is is that he's
in a rush I have a feeling that's going
to come back to bite him in the ass
later though i think missy is going to
be someone that's really gonna surprise
him but question number 7 Aaliyah
Aaliyah asks what if the boy under the
blanket wasn't the doctor but the master
that is a really interesting thought it
would definitely be a huge WTF twist the
reason I don't think that's the case the
TARDIS was basically traveling along her
time stream so for it to take her to the
master she would have at some time in
her past had to interact with him in a
substantial way there was Gallifrey and
Clara but I think that's reaching a bit
far there was someone in the comments
that did suggest that the doctor might
have been crying because it was around
the time he and the master might have
been exposed to the untempered schism
that moment whenever the master started
to hear the drum beats that is a totally
amazing theory I don't think it's what
Moffat necessarily intended to imply
whenever he wrote the scene I think he
just wanted us to see the doctor having
a nightmare but on to question number 8
the Elijah talk asks can we mention that
it's implied Clara and Danny settle down
I definitely think that it's implied but
i think that whenever Orson pink was
talking about time travel running in the
family he was just making a bit of a
generalization he could have just been
referencing Danny Pink's run-ins with
car and the doctor not that they ended
up getting married and having children
although that's also totally possible I
don't want to make too many Clara and
Danny theories before seeing the finale
just because supposedly there are some
really crazy things happening that would
negate a lot of those theories
companions do totally get to settle down
but a lot of times they don't get happy
endings you know like Amy and Rory did
get married they had a child but they
still got taken by the weeping angels
but on to question number nine walking
who while you're really gonna like
Sunday's in a couple weeks how do you
feel about the doctor not knowing where
they were during the barn scene do you
think that he should know assuming that
he doesn't know like and he's not just
faking that he doesn't know I think it's
totally okay the scene where Clara told
him never to go back was more about him
trusting her and the idea of broken
trust i think is going to be a really
big deal over the course of series 8 the
doctor trusting people and then breaking
that trust people trusting the doctor
and him breaking that trust I think it's
all going to play into whatever the
Missy plot is on to question number 10
Rob rub asks with both the episode and
Doctor Who extra making deliberate
references to the doctors past will we
see a Moffat loop that takes the story
back to another big first
her moment like stealing the TARDIS I
like that you called it a Moffat loop
like a mobius strip of story or
something I do think that Missy will
have something to do with his ancient
past like back to the first doctor but I
don't think it's going to be related to
him stealing the TARDIS I think it'll be
like a big moment from his past that we
haven't ever seen before if the story
does end up going back into the past I
don't expect to see a lot of other
versions of the doctor just because they
kind of did that in the series seven
finale thank you so much for submitting
questions though I don't think that will
ever be completely satisfied with barn
theories but that's just one more
question to ask Moffat if you ever get
to ask him in real life since episode 5
t some really big criminals from Doctor
Who's history I think my next bonus
video is gonna be for my favorite doctor
who criminals so be sure to subscribe to
get that and gradual ations to this
week's giveaway winner Doge fresh you
win the gift certificate this week I'll
be reaching out to you and your channel
for details so be sure to check your
inbox everyone remember that the next
round will start whenever I post my
episode 5 video but in the meantime you
can click here for my episode 4 review
and you can click here for my top 5 of
scary doctor who episodes thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives
you